[Music]
thank you
[Music]
1989 November the fmln which is the
gorilla that then became a political
party in El Salvador launched their
final offensive which was called
offensive
because that was their final push to
take the capital an intense Urban
fighting came into place around San
Salvador and they took hotels one of the
hotels they took they didn't realize at
the time that the High Commissioner of
the UN was held captive there and they
fought with Marines U.S Marines for a
long period of time up until they
realized that they messed up with
somebody who wasn't supposed to be there
and they released him and they they let
the gorillas go away and that was the
turning point on that specific attack
and then negotiations took place for
several peace agreements in this hotel
that we are standing here so this is
someone what an iconic place
is full of History bloody history
[Music]
so there was this one Congressman
Francisco Marino and he has this
incident with the police where he was
drunk driving and he shot a policewoman
and this was a huge Scandal he's uh you
as you would imagine his picture
appeared in all the newspapers he was
from a small party that was like a like
a swing party the the siren and back
then the assembly was right-wing Arena
related to the dead squads in the in the
war and Guerrilla fmln because you
cannot really arrest
Congressman he's taken to a sort of
impeachment trial and in that process
Arena says okay we're gonna not impeach
your Congressman but you're gonna give
us the vote for a little legislation it
was not a matter of if this is
convenient for the people if this is
what the people won but it was a matter
of do you have the votes and how can you
get the votes because this is something
that the elites won
in that moment we have NAFTA
but the opposition was uh in that time
fmln
for mercury land you know like
imperialism junk intervention
privatization of the banks the
communications the electricity companies
everything so that happened hand in hand
with the dollarization yes it was in
2001.
many call centers arrived to the country
and I'm a Italian speaker so I got a job
in an Italian account and I got a very
good salary so for me it was good to
have the dollar for the regular people
was very bad
sometimes it feels like you don't have
another option
if you leave a call center
you will not find another job or there
will be nothing else that you can do
with uh with I mean where can I get
money so how I'm going to survive
[Music]
there was no technical debate that was
on the basis of the approval of the law
that people did not have immediately
clear
how and why would we benefit of changing
our currency to whether we were like
trapped into the void of dollarization
and the Savage neoliberalism you know
since that moment
there was essentially a rug bull
that was financed by the lower income
classes there's no loans unless you have
land so our
ex that
we we've had to continue working but as
a collateral we've been losing property
after property
the dollar increase
prizes
increase uh pigments for rent so I
consider it uh decrease the quality of
life of the average population here in
the country
for example you could get a pound of
tomatoes for five colonies one dollar
it's equal to
8.75 colonies so since that moment you
are not paying five colonies but you are
paying a dollar
I'm sure inflation uh slowed down a
couple of points I'm sure uh Colones
would now be a lot
well uh more worthless than they were
like that
as a struggle in society it increased
violence it increase the lack of
opportunities for people
my neighbors all of them move away to
the United States
the friends I made from childhood all of
them moved
not having a
a salary
or even a formal job you know we have
almost 80 percent of informal Commerce
here in the country so not everyone has
quite the chance or even having a bank
account in the country so
the gap between rich and poor increased
since the dollar got here in the country
[Music]
we were at the midpoint of being
governed or ruled by a right-wing policy
that implemented all the new liberal
policies existed like directly from IMS
directly from uh the Canadian School
directly from whatever the multilaterals
one is in the hindsights they were in
cahoots with one another and
co-governing they saw homicide rights go
up they saw economical rates never take
off immigration kept surging towards the
USA
it was like War I actually was thinking
wearing wire and nobody has declared it
but so many people is dying people have
been lied to stolen from the throne in
jail for nonsense for 30 years in Comes
This Savvy politician who is a
mastermind of social media who had been
part of flm and knew them as a whole but
also was seen as a challenging young
gravel kind of guy in their family for
us it's all about modernizing the
country regardless if you agree or not
with the government we need to do this
for El Salvador it doesn't matter what
what type of ideology you have and then
he ran on the presidential race his most
famous slogan is
which is there's enough money if people
don't steal it really about pushing our
country forward so we can we can go into
into the future and make a better
country for the new generations he won a
landslide election and he again won a
landslide election to control the
majority of the Congress and up to that
point are so good there have been
reforms and now it seems that the
judicial branch is favorable to the
university that's party so I don't
there's been a lot of hurray in Western
press about this being a coup or some
kind of undemocratic effort and you know
the facts thought life you put in the
work to find out how this all played out
and so unless someone can prove to me
that they stole the election somehow
they won fair and square and they are
following their constitution political
opposition
because both the right wing party arena
in the left-wing party fmln were really
corrupt this is the will of the people
and he is dearly loved and and approved
of by most people I was six years in
Congress
and then I run for president the first
time the political party was Arena
and I didn't finish the campaign
I saw too much corruption
[Music]
we want El Salvador to become the next
Singapore absolutely and it's not just
an idea that president bukele has shared
you know even publicly I mean you can
read it once in a while on Twitter he
should tweets Singapore and that's it
wait he's saying a lot with that and for
us who in my case I work in Tech
investment and I understand that
anything in everything educational
Health water everything relates to
technology and if we modernize the
country and are able to bring investment
the necessary investment in order to
make it run in a more efficient way then
yes absolutely we will become the next
Singapore at least in the Latin American
region and I can tell you that is the
goal yes
foreign
[Music]
town a fisherman town the first tourists
that came here were surfers
surfing changed her life here had been
always part of our history of life
when we started using Bitcoin or social
projects Bitcoin Beach or something
starts to be in the focus of many people
all around the world many people that
hear that in this little town these guys
this group of young people
start to creating the first Circle
economy all around the world based on
bitcoin
I have been witnessed yes there's still
crime at azonte we cannot deny it yes
they're still
garbage thrown away but not as much as
it were a couple of years ago
we came working for more than 10 years
ago
with this big dream to change her
community to and how we're going to
change her community giving tools to the
young people that they can start to
fight for their dreams here and stop
dreaming to go to the United States and
working there
the government realized that this was a
way
to implement these main ideas of values
and freedom and and inclusion and and
prevention of violence and education and
how this can be a recreated elsewhere
and I think that's what we inherited
from the elfonte program this dream
started here in Sante we never thought
that our project will
inspire a nation without him Bitcoin as
a legal tender
[Music]
first time I heard about this was
from a conference in Miami Beach from my
white guy who says that now he and he's
introducing the president of my country
and says this is going to be your legal
tender president was running as a
candidate for the presidential election
a lot of proposals if you will were
given to the population and there's
actually a digital agenda on the
president's website that anybody can
have access to it's also in English and
they can see the pillars in which we are
focusing on as a country
however
Bitcoin was not included in that digital
agenda in 2019 however we saw the need
to adopt anything that could take us
faster in a more consistent way into the
future
so the logical thing to do was to move
forward and adopt the most uh famous
well-known and in this case secure coin
and that was Bitcoin it was a no-brainer
[Music]
in short sweet terms it made Bitcoin
legal tender in El Salvador
period
with all of the legal implication that
that has
I would say that when Bitcoin law uh
came down this was kind of a repetition
of the terrorization bill but faster
Bitcoin law was announced on a Sunday
and on Wednesday it was approved as a
legal tender in El Salvador and you
could probably say a lot of the same
technical critics that you say to the
organization you could also just
translate 20 years in the future and say
the same about Bitcoin
was like a pretty cool decision so it
was a surprise a surprising thing for
everyone in the country and even for
bitcoiners of the country the legal
Community but us they thought that this
was
full gold that was being introduced into
the economic system
so I think it's like a battle you know
between education and no education and
an open-minded idea for people let them
know what can they do with a tool that
could like
give us freedom the risk here it's to be
free so I consider people doesn't know
about the benefits of being free because
they always been like I don't know what
the government said or other sets you
know but it's time for us to get
personal sovereignty and decided about a
real freedom
thank you
[Music]
president vehicle is immensely popular
like hitting 80 charts and approval
rates and Bitcoin was the first
unpopular move that he made
what is the long-term
effect that this is going to have right
this decision made for us is gonna have
and I think that the most part of the
fear that it that we have
as a population is that when we got
dollarized
was the same speech about like having
two
legal currencies but
it went the the cologne went out of
circulation because
we don't know why
we have been going through this rural
places in this small towns outside of
the capital outside of San Salvador in
the Salvadorian perspective it's been a
very political perspective so um people
in the
um honestly all around the country but
most part in the rural zones in the
country that they don't know or think
about Bitcoin they just think that this
is a buccales coin or or this is similar
to dollar or they think that the dollar
is going to disappear after this that's
all they have heard from the television
from the news
[Music]
like in any democracy I think opposition
is healthy I actually think they will
they will be there in any country and
they should be there in order to Balance
power but at the same time it's
interesting to see that people who are
against the president or who are against
the government are also against Bitcoin
just because you need to be against you
know anything that the government does
and that's a huge mistake because
they're not really informing themselves
or educating themselves in regards to
what Bitcoin can do for them in regards
to gaining not only Financial Freedom
but at the same time allowing them to
save and to invest in another medium
that is the future so yes there were
people who were against it there were
organizations who were against it but at
the end of the day we knew that this was
the right thing to do the government had
a big issue even with their Bitcoin
community on the article 7 of the law
which says it's mandatory that's not
being really implemented so the
government is not enforcing that of the
law and so that's made people kind of
like okay it's not gonna affect me I
don't have to buy into it
[Music]
I went out to the park to do some
exercise
it was a Sunday normally on a Sunday
there's almost nobody there but there
were some people there and I remember oh
there was a process is going to be today
there were four types of people in that
protest
it was some rich people who comes in big
bands in big cars you know there's been
another inflation
with the Bitcoins you can ask people
tell me a bit about that I believe that
since the Bitcoin was
adopted as a legal currency I believe
that
prices went around 40 to 50 percent
inflation and probably it will come
tomorrow
everything if you go to the grocery you
do your groceries if you go to a
restaurant
they have a few percentage around 40 and
50 percent they're not gonna tell you
the owners of the restaurants but if you
know the prices and you go again and you
see the prices with the Bitcoins it came
up everything has come out if you go to
the
so where people buy their groceries not
the supermarket it's like a central area
where you buy uh you know less than the
grocery
people are gonna tell you
that they got a little percentage more
because they don't know what's gonna
happen with Bitcoin if it's gonna go up
gonna go down if it's gonna be stable or
not
the Bitcoin is it's
it's like this I mean it's not every
second it's moving you know you have
seen the application it's moving every
second but they made this because they
don't have any choice they don't have
more dollars
so they're gonna run out of money and
that's why they're cut their plan B is a
Bitcoin you said there were four types
yes rich people rich people very very
poor people who came from other far away
places from the country very clearly you
can see on the streets when you if you
if you went to the protest it wasn't
about Bitcoin the anti-bitcoin idea was
just the one flag that they could raise
that somehow got more people to show up
but there were many concerns being
expressed by people uh out in in the
protest but that's like the one thing
that they could cling on to journalists
Bitcoin plays into the grand scheme of
things because it allows him to have
positive attention of the world and
present himself as this cool Savvy
president politician to the world went
internationally and initially he has
been critiqued and questioned over this
authoritarian Tendencies and young
people like me who is really convinced
that convinced that Bitcoin is a bad
thing for the country
so for me the last the last type of
people that are that I described is are
the Royal protesters right they actually
think that it's about it's a bad thing
that there is corruption and they go in
the government
and when I saw in the media
big protest in El Salvador I was like
that's not real I mean salvadorians
don't fully support Bitcoin like knowing
what it is and it's going to be the best
thing for a country we are not like that
but also with on the post to it if
you're against the government you will
see you will be against Bitcoin without
even like getting to know really what it
is there is a very vocal and vociferous
opposition but they keep painting
themselves into a corner where they
could have understood that Bitcoin was
their greatest Ally and yet for whatever
reason they've chosen to cancel
themselves out of Bitcoin at least for
the first semester we'll see how next
year plays out
take people from zero to one we're
teaching a basic stuff basic concepts
about Bitcoin and try to guide them on
how to use wallets for example how to
identify different concepts from Bitcoin
like centralized or decentralized we're
talking about wallets in general and and
what's a non-custodial wallet where's
the custodial wallet which is the
mindset about money about what people
are used to be how we grew up thinking
that money is
is uh something that you can touch
and
explain that to people that they never
have access to the bank account they
never have access to the credit card to
the debit card to start to understanding
what is digitally money and just jump
into the Bitcoin now
is
it's exciting it's exciting but it took
time and there are some people that get
it they understand it in the beginning
and their life have been changing
[Music]
we won't be able to dream about becoming
the next Singapore if we do not push for
Education providing the necessary space
for more programmers and developers
because those are really the careers of
the future at the same time right now
that Bitcoin is legal
allowing people on the street you know
the regular citizen who sells uh gum or
candies on the street to teach them how
to use the chibo wallet or any other
wallet it doesn't matter as long as they
use Bitcoin but the key will be in not
just the government but also Academia
and the private sector to unite in order
to do this
words
the first student that I got he's a Uber
driver and actually
after I think that it was the second
class
he got up at least a general idea how
received Bitcoin how transactions work
on change and on lighting
and
he says well
now that we are we are getting a lot of
people from other countries they're
gonna get interested if they can make a
payment a Bitcoin and he did a a fair
amount of such on his trips and I I meet
him the past week and asked him hey be
honest what do you do without such and
he said hey I'm holding we start to see
how we can use it in the social
initiative
and paying the English classes with
Bitcoin being the young people to clean
it no pain but giving them like a bonus
you know that they can use it in the
purpose area they can use it to buy
internet to be able to to do their
homeworks you know and some families had
also like a progress to find like a jobs
and we started offering like jobs and
paying the Bitcoin this was the
beginning of this big movement that now
we all know and everyone know about
Bitcoin Beach
I didn't have to know how to program we
just have to do small tasks and I was
able to do it whenever I wanted and I
had the option to pay through PayPal or
Bitcoin so at the beginning I started
asking me through Bible with the logic
inconveniences of anti-money laundering
regulations being as strong as they are
in a country as violent as El Salvador
we are passed through country from
Colombia and South America to the US
which means that the narcos use us as an
intermediate point and this is something
that has made the US government and
other international government agencies
to force El Salvador to implement huge
anti-money laundering regulations I used
to hold it
and they paid me each week
when I had a big amount I used to bring
it to the country because PayPal is
banned from the country you cannot bring
money with you if you have it in PayPal
I used to send it from my PayPal account
to a friend of mine and he used to send
it to me through Western Union on that
doing that I used to lose 20 of my of my
money so it was really hard for me but
does it was the only way I had
my bank accounts are being closed I am
being investigated by the fiscalia
because they I I have been doing
irregular transactions coming from
anywhere in the world to my bank account
now with Bitcoin they deposit deposited
directly to my wallet I don't lose
almost anything
foreign
Bitcoin is still only a governmental
subsidy something that you open up an
app in a cell phone and it allowed you
to have thirty dollars to use in
something a friend of mine yes me can
you do as a drawing can you make a
drawing of us when she was going to pay
me she was like I can deposit to your
bank account because she was in San
Miguel I was here in San Salvador it was
a Saturday night and she said on Monday
I will wake up early and I will go to
the bank I will be careful because of
Soviet I don't like waking up early but
I will have to go I will deposit your
money and I was like you can just send
me the payment through Bitcoin
and she was like really and
it was a matter of some minutes I mean
in a matter of minutes I had the money
in my wallet
she said oh my God that's a relief I
didn't know it was that fast
I have received several payments through
that way was this after the 30 dollars
from chivo yes
being a legal tender now allows us to
easily convert from US dollar to for or
if any fiat currency to bitcoin and vice
versa it's seamless it's delightful in
the sense that there's a there's a small
business person I am able to reduce
operating costs Financial costs from
having to go through the usual suspects
or her or the financial institutions
during a Salvador we don't we don't
really use Unchained that much because
the fees are very high and we're making
a lot of transactions per day so we
prefer to use the lightning Network
because it's um it's faster and it's
easier and no fees in the most most of
the cases or fees are very low we had
the Espresso Bar everybody that came at
least 80 percent of uh individuals
particularly requested lightning Network
to make their transactions so I was
happy to also learn about the various
wallets out there and the pros and the
cons it was a pleasant experience so it
wasn't as hard as one imagines the first
patient I had pain Bitcoin was a 64 year
old person that it's a construction
worker he doesn't know how to read but
he has some lightning wallet you know so
he had a previously education in the use
of alignment wallet the value of money
our crowdfunding Bitcoin is miles we
have currently uh 1.8 Bitcoin to work
and provide critical dental care for the
impoverished communities so Bitcoin
fixes teeth as well
when did they can come to our community
we start to see people saving money for
the first time people buying like an
asset for the first time small Merchants
transacting digitally accepting payment
making digitally payment for the first
time
for many people this is sounds like not
like a big issues right because you
don't see the problem if you don't live
in the problems but for
people from Europe from the United
States from Canada maybe when they go to
the coffee shop and they order a coffee
is is normal to get like a debit card a
credit card and pay digitally but that's
a luxur that not everyone have all
around the world that Bitcoin have been
representing that for this side of the
world you know giving access to our
population
seventy percent of our population in the
South didn't have access to the
financial system to the actual Financial
system but now more than 4 million
people in your Sabbath have access to
the new Financial system
they can receive the remedies in in
their wallet
without someone that say
no you cannot do it
we all can use it in different ways and
every human people can benefit from that
it's just understanding what Bitcoin
represent him for you for us have been
representing access to the financial
system
for the majority of the people they see
Bitcoin just like an asset but people
need to understand also that Bitcoin is
a monetary Network this concept is
for people to understand it's like
Bitcoin is going to be like internet
Bitcoin is gonna be in the center
[Music]
our purpose is to establish a genuine
direct trade relationships with our
final consumers is that we're roasting
here at origin and exporting directly to
customers who are willing to pay via
lightning Network eliminating financial
institution High commission and another
transaction costs associated with banks
down here
Satoshi blend is an idea of Financial
Freedom we chose the sanpacho varietal
of Arabica Harvest as well as the red
bourbon because of the quality and
because of the association and meaning
it has related to the coffee rust
disease that impacted coffee producer
countries a decade ago
we call it Green Bean or gold
this is our goal this is our Bitcoin
foreign
[Music]
Matrix that we have allows us to take
advantage of the geothermal power
alternative to the petroleum oil bunker
oil fuel so here where we are now near
Guatemala we're about one kilometer
north of Lake they have a headquarters
here in awachapan also and as you drive
you can see all the all the gas coming
out of the the mountains and the
volcanoes so all that it will enable us
also to maybe in the future have another
cluster of of
Bitcoin mining activity
the day the video of president bukele
during the Bitcoin
2021 conference uh was broadcasted he
went on on a Twitter space along with
many other people right so we all
followed him he was asked
so what do you think about mining is El
Salvador going to mine Bitcoin and right
at that time she was out of the blue and
I'm saying it wasn't something that had
been planned ahead of time he he said
well we have plenty of volcanoes in fact
we have 23 volcanoes in El Salvador and
he said I think we should we shoot mine
with our volcano energy and he blew
everybody's Minds because we hadn't even
thought about it honestly it shows you
two things one how something that
perhaps had not been thought of around
the world can be done in a country like
El Salvador one of the tiniest countries
in all of Latin America and two how we
also have a leader who's not only a
millennial but an innovator
and we have a mining plant in Berlin and
it's it's utilizing geothermal energy
the plant is surrounded by volcanoes and
it's just incredible that we're actually
doing this but at the same time that
we're also getting support from other
companies
it's great that they will have more
investment in new energy infrastructure
they need to have more energy to produce
and developed and available in this
Salvador from Salvadorian sources
there's a lot of opportunity and I hope
that Salvador becomes the you know
Pioneer and world leader of geothermal
energy my understanding is that
geothermal in El Salvador for it to go
to mining would need to be new geotherm
and we need to know more about the lead
times there
foreign
[Music]
from another country tell you
hey what do you what is your opinion on
bitcoin or what do you think of Bitcoin
so brother is going to give you an
honest answer I don't know I don't
understand but if you if you say do you
want to you know maybe I will share some
knowledge of Bitcoin with you they're
gonna
maybe I'm excited but I I fully sure
that a 99 of Salvadoran is gonna say
yeah let's talk about Bitcoin and even
if they don't accept Bitcoin they're
gonna say yeah let's talk about Bitcoin
and they really appreciate that you are
sharing with it with them knowledge if
you meet someone that's anti-bitcoin in
El Salvador please be patient and listen
to their arguments because you will
realize that they're just confused and
they just need someone to help guide
them along their orange pill Journey
I see many tourists that when they come
here they sit with the locals and
talking and is really exciting seeing
tourism changing their mindset about
Bitcoin
and the locals also
have their parents more opens to learn
from there because in places like El
Salvador or Latin America we grew up
thinking that the bad things are in
Europe the bad things are in Canada in
the United States
but when people come here and they're
super exciting and they're like wow this
is a big dream but is it like a big
dream of everyone
see tourism
changing their mindset and saying like
well before I came to El Salvador I
didn't want to spend my thoughts my
Bitcoin once I'm here I'm more willing
to do it to help people
because Bitcoin representing that bit on
representing
that chance
to make
this place a better place for this
generation but also for the Next
Generation that are coming
the government cannot educate its entire
population on bitcoin or on any other
related topic we need help and we have
to do it hand in hand with the Academia
with companies meaning the private
sector and investors from the outside or
companies who have started arriving into
El Salvador opening offices and
recruiting staff and I've been seeing it
because I've been on boarding many of
these companies so if we all work
together the experience the Bitcoin
experiment in El Salvador is going to be
a success and we all wanted to be a
success because if if it works out here
in a country that has a population of
6.5 million it's going to work out
anywhere we just need to keep on pushing
and educating our population
[Music]
we believe that hyperbacconization is
the most important race of the 21st
century and for whatever reason Central
America has a unique situation where we
are perfectly poised to win that race
and we think it's the only race that
will matter in the 21st century so
everything we can do to increase the
odds of Central America winning that
race we are here to do
[Music]
is one of the Departments the 14
departments that make up El Salvador and
when the announcement was made last
Saturday by the president of Bitcoin
City to reactivate the economic activity
in the East for all of us we were very
happy because it's progress for the
country that means less people are going
to have to migrate to the city it's
going to decentralize bitcoin city is
going to be built very close to Samuel
where I was born
it's cultural context
what does it mean for a Salvadorian
what does it mean that this Bitcoin
series is going to be built in lonia and
not in the center of the country
historically those cities has been
abandoned or in the Oblivion because
through all our history in El Salvador
every development every Improvement has
been in the capital city it will give
opportunities to the people who lives
there and they will not have to move to
leave their families
foreign
government that has a deficit in its
budget it needs to get new liquidity
from creditors traditional creditors the
lender of Last Resort the IMF
is the only one on the table right now
for El Salvador for the traditional Fiat
blending to see if El Salvador can
extend beyond the 100 that GDP to you
know United States levels of 130 that
the GDP but in order to do that
obviously there are some considerable
strings attached and I try to put myself
in their shoes if your party is known as
nuevas idas literally new ideas
and in order to finance them the one
person that shows up at the table is the
lender of Last Resort and their
financing comes with all of these
strings essentially you're being asked
to go from the party of new ideas to
call yourself the party of new ideas but
financing the same old ideas
so
I can understand perfectly why they have
chosen to stick their middle finger in
front of the IMF but I don't even know
if it's just that I think they are
playing them I think what they realize
is that their Bitcoin at this point has
matured to the point where there's
another player that they can sit down at
the table with and that's Bitcoin
it seems that in this iteration it's
blackstream and bitfinex and great for
them I think what they are demonstrating
is that nation states that are facing a
similar situation to what is a lot is
facing with Fiat in the petrol dollar
system have another
option have a Lifeboat a life raft that
they can grab onto the same way that
many individuals that have found Bitcoin
have seen Bitcoin as a life rep so
I believe that they're still negotiating
with the IMF there's still a possibility
that the IMF gives them provides some
sort of financing but for this new
financing is it different it can be
we'll have to look at the details in the
bond you know how how is it structured
what are the rules like what is an
investor actually buying but it would
seem that through liquid the side chain
where these bonds are going to be
available almost anyone in the world is
going to be able to buy these in small
amounts as well so it's a Brave New
World really for for financing states
that are leading their people in the
direction that other creditors are
willing to support
so
as long as the government uses those
proceeds
well
and so the conditions that I saw was 50
for the purchase of Bitcoin for custody
I'd love to see the details on who's
costing you know how is that both I
think going to work it would be very
good to know but then the remaining 500
million is supposed to be invested in
Salvadorian energy and other kinds of
infrastructure to lay the groundwork for
a Bitcoin City so if we do not see
results from those Investments so this
is the case every in every plant every
country on the planet of all this
financing that comes from the
traditional Fiat retro dollar and it's
like oh yeah they paid 100 million
dollars for reports that never showed up
so
um if now you're relying on a creditor
that has the ability to you know take
their money off the table and not seen
as a as a creditor of Last Resort then
they have to keep our interest right
we'll see if uh bitcoiners actually
played play it that way and and and if
there is corruption if they are stealing
the money will bitcoiners no longer buy
the Bots right that'll will have to
verify and for now my my message would
be just don't trust verify foreign
I feel really proud to be in the middle
of the public eye
not for bad things not for a war not for
gangs not from violence not from being
the murder capital of the world I will
talk to my grandchildren that I lived in
this in this era of change this is our
version of The Fall of the wall of
Berlin
is the adoption of Bitcoin and it's
gonna it's sending shock waves around
the world I considered that Bitcoin it's
a tool that it's going to change
Humanity the change we are living in and
it's going to provide hope
in our case our country suffers too much
and it's time to stop suffering it's
time to believe in ourselves it's the
time for take action
[Music]
we need the most help from everywhere in
the world of people that really
understand are into Bitcoin and really
understand the benefits and
if they have a way to
um provide something and help us as a
community to grow El Salvador is making
history is leading this new Revolution
it's leading these new dream this new
freedom
I have 25 years old and I never get any
kind of interesting in politics I mean I
hear my father I hear my uncles even so
my grandfathers hear about politics and
things like that
but I never never seen on my good days
on my John's days anything that politics
really do and generate an impact here on
this other and you know what happens
that we we came we came out from a civil
conflict it's not not too too much time
has passed after that and I think that
the Goons uh was still fresh a couple of
decades ago and that is the main reason
that politics never did something that
generates an impact and what happens now
is that president came and actually
begins to see things that a lot of
people see you know
as example
if you ask me the previous president
what does he do the benefits you or
generate an impact in your life my
honest answer is gonna be I don't know
but if my kids in the future asked me
what president did in his time that
makes an impact on your life my answer
is gonna be Bitcoin hey we come
from
being forced into adopting
political views political ways of
thinking
from both ends
from the Communist and capitalists that
haven't done any good for us as
salvadorians we have been forced either
you're with one side or with the other
and I will kill you if you do not agree
with me and that led to a Civil War and
that led to coups and that led to be us
being one of the poorest economies in
the world
and now with this I see it as a game
changer I I used to draw in my art that
people or violence
and now
and I realized that Del Salvador was
exporting
feelings of death feelings a very very
negative feelings because that's our
history that's what we live
but I don't want and just I want to to
stress that a lot I don't want to be
like that anymore that said that I can I
can tell that the general feeling of the
population we don't want to be like that
anymore
we want to leave that in the past
the spirit of the country was lost the
spirit of the country was death and now
we can at least dream of something that
keeps us alive that make us think maybe
our
Sons or daughters will not have to go to
the United States to live maybe we will
not have to say goodbye to them anymore
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
PR and it's too soon for actually to be
changing the lives of millions of people
[Music]
foreign